so uh like General overview
um so the game is essentially about uh
alternate history sort of Russia 1940s
1950s where uh basically Russia uh you
know scientists a specific scientist in
Russia has come up with something that
they call like a polymer right and
essentially it's something that you can
inject into your body right and this is
like a futuristic world right one of
those features World War II
um they didn't well they they talk they
talk about the Nazis and then they they
talk about how they came out of it you
know they talk about atrocities like
there's this one scene where they have
like a monument and you see like you
know the the fake accomplishments and
stuff like that but in the intersperse
real stuff in there as well so coming
out of that war oh you read the wall
yeah yeah I read the wall yeah so you
coming coming out of the war right it's
like okay the scientist comes up with
this with this amazing thing supposedly
the Nazis